any sufficiently advanced technology
is indistinguishable from magic
[Music]
and today we are very fortunate to be
joined by a renowned uh scientist
and also a local a local san diegan who
is benefiting as i am from the end of
may gray june gloom
july we didn't fry it's finally clear
it's august 2nd and i'm joined by eric
dr eric topel how are you today dr toefl
brian i'm so great to be with you thank
you for having me with you
i've i followed you for years obviously
your renowned scientist cardiologist
executive
uh vice president
at scripps institution which is not to
be confused with scripps institute of
oceanography i made that mistake in the
past
we had on uh
luca legiani who is at scripps
institution he works on origin of life
we talked about origin of life primo
levy this is life month on the into the
impossible podcast uh but before we get
into uh all these physics and kind of
nerd out on physical sciences i wanna do
what i do
eric with all my guests who write books
and you've written at least three that
i've read
i like to play a game called judging
books by their cover because what other
prior do you have to go on when you see
a book
uh and so i want to ask you uh this book
deep medicine i have your other book the
patient will see you now in another room
but this book deep medicine what is the
origin of the title and the subtitle and
the cover design which seems to have a
menacing android
right well deep medicine was easy
because um
this is about how deep learning the
subtype of ai will affect the future of
medicine and health care
and uh
you know i think
in many ways one of my
influencers was gary
kasparov who had a book deep thinking
and it's a natural d it's deep
everything as you know brian uh all the
all the uh different
methods and acronyms everything
surrounding the deep learning era is
deep and what's the the play on words
here is that rather than everybody
thinking about the ai
impact it's much more about
restoring humanity
going deep in terms of the human
connection and that's what i think is
the the counter-intuitive notion so then
that picture of the android with the
apple was trying to to capture that
sense is that
we
we can make
with ai
uh
medicine better
healthier and then restore the human
connect which is the whole
notion that most people haven't realized
that the gift of time
that if you
harness what ai can do
between
all the different things like
the
assimilation of the data processing the
data that no human being
uh can actually keep up with anymore uh
so that and the idea that you for
example you know doctors are in
clinicians or keyboards typing and not
even looking at patients and you know
why why that well you would use voice
and natural language processing and get
synthetic notes and there's a long long
list of things that would make that
patient doctor relationship back to the
way it was supposed to be back where it
was years ago when i
first
got out of medical school
yeah and uh i want to also point out
that
i know that you have many awards and
honors uh in addition to
your leadership at scripps institute uh
institution uh but i want to also point
out that you were named if i'm not
mistaken 2017 uh sharpie highlighter uh
man of the year for all your highlights
that you do in your tweets
i decided i would start emulating you uh
when i heard you speak uh you are
perhaps the most prolific highlighter in
human history and i say that uh based on
your meeting you in real life and seeing
you on twitter where you're uh been a
godsend to many of us who are data
driven and like to think about data et
cetera
more or less continuously and i do want
to get into the opportunities that you
presented to me and to the audience back
at scripps when you gave a lecture when
this book came out but also yeah as you
mentioned and the patient will see you
now you kind of had this this uh
depiction at one point i remember and
talk you gave you know like a doc you
know in the olden days it was like a
doctor looking at a chart and and the
patient's sitting there talking and now
it's like a doctor typing into a
computer
and i think about that with education
in that you know a thousand years ago in
bologna italy the first university was
started and you're also a professor of
of uh
at scripps as well and uh those first
professors you know think of how much
has changed it was a man with a piece of
rock scraping on another piece of rock
you know writing down something and then
there were students were transferring it
to their pieces of rock or papyr i don't
know what they had back then to be
honest eric but but the point is nothing
has changed in education it to like if
you were explaining it you know maybe
yeah we have these devices and now the
comp the kids are recording instead of
typing notes are writing notes by hand
but um but it strikes me as how little
has changed in hundreds if not thousands
of years and and uh you know we're kind
of at this level as i had on carl wyman
who won the nobel prize in 2001 who's
now turned his life to educational
overhaul and he said you know he claimed
we're at the point in education that's
equivalent to bloodletting with leeches
but i want to ask you what is medicine
at you know
um how come medicine is so resistant is
it all lawyers is it because of lawyers
or why is it that we haven't we don't
have an artificial
intern in the room with all my doctors
yeah great question ryan um you know i
think one of the big reasons why
medicine is so sclerotic
so
difficult to change and as you say many
things are a throwback to more than two
millennia
the era of hippocrates where the doctor
knows best about everything and is in
command and control of everything and so
letting go
is difficult and it's not just a legal
thing it's much more you know it's this
thing of i'm in charge i'm trained to be
in charge and and also i'm a tr i want
to live in an analog world
uh part of that analog world was that
the first foray into the digital world
in medicine with these electronic health
records which has been have been an
abject uh you know a total fiasco
because what it's done is it basically
really undermined that relationship as
you've already touched on and um
the problem is that that's not a good
proxy for where digital
and where things like ai can take us uh
and so a lot of a lot of physicians
where they were forced to change
their health system said you must use
electronic records we're getting rid of
paper records
and it just it was all done for billing
purposes it wasn't done to you know
providing better medical care so
with that the the first chance to adopt
the digital era in health care it
backfired
in many respects so we between
what you mentioned the medical legal
issues the control issues the
bad experiences sour experiences it's
been hard to get
any real substantive change in medicine
and i look at you know the work of your
colleague and friend atel gawande in his
book the checklist manifesto you know
there's kind of rationalizing
systematizing and i'm a private pilot i
fly little mining cessnas around but but
the point being you know we've learned
because the lessons are written in blood
and aviation you know that you have to
learn from the mistakes of others
because you won't live long enough to
make them all yourself as rick over said
but i guess the thing that strikes to me
is even more similar is that like
artificial intelligence could be in the
cockpit too in other words every time i
fly you know from montgomery field or
whatever and i fly around to go to i
don't know uh los angeles or something
like that i have to tune in by hand a
radio dial and i have to listen uh
analog single bit you know single
channel communication to the weather
there because there could be a broken
down plane on the runway and so it
changes every hour and uh and then i
have to write that down by look what if
i hadn't you know and i won't say the
word but it sounds like alexandria or or
cyril and i had one of these devices in
the cockpit with me that was connected
because connected to the internet
through you know 5g or whatever um and
it strikes me as is just as you say
sclerotic because
that would save lives i mean there's no
doubt that there have been lives lost
because either someone didn't check
didn't tune the right frequency um
didn't know there was something that
prevented them from being able to land
for example and probably in medicine too
there's people that
yeah go ahead yeah well brian you're
really apt to point that out because
the problem we have with medicine today
is you know this this term precision
medicines
used a lot
and that doesn't mean much if you keep
making the same mistakes that's very
precise we need accuracy and that's
actually the me the short term
big benefit of ai deep neural networks
are you start to see all the trends
particularly with medical images
of making things far more accurate that
is when you get the processing that can
be done
through training neural nets of
hundreds of thousands if not millions of
whether it's mammograms or x-rays cat
scans i mean any type of medical image
you can do things that no one would have
anticipated in terms of revving up
accuracy and when you add the human
oversight
then you've got kind of the best of both
worlds so that's why medicine is in the
midst uh i would say in the early miss
of a shake-up because the machine plus
the clinician is going to be the the new
look rather than just the clinician
because accuracy is not anywhere near it
needs to be in fact the national academy
of medicine has documented that each of
us will have a serious medical error
happened to us in our lifetime
you know at least one that's pretty bad
and then when you also think about the
40 of doctors
when a patient dies
and they have an autopsy and before the
autopsy they say
40 of the time that is
they know exactly what was the cause of
death and the autopsy 40 times shows
they're absolutely wrong
so we have a lot of hubris right a lot
of inaccuracy and we need help we need
to lean on machines to help us
yeah and i think that's something that's
you know again in the aviation the
military they've learned this i had uh
david markey on the podcast last year
and he's talking yeah his book turned
the ship around and leadership is
language and he told me the most
dangerous word a leader a surgeon a
pilot someone can say is the word right
question mark you know i say to you eric
you know like i don't i'm not going to
suffer from covet right you know it's
like it's and you're in a position of
authority it's coercive it's it's
manipulative it's it's um prone to
confirmation bias and i just wonder you
know i always hearken back to the talmud
which is the second holiest book in
judaism and the talmud has a famous
phrase i don't know if you ever heard it
the best doctors go to hell
because we do and i extend that to phd
doctors
it's not the worst doctor it's because
yeah we we kind of have this this theme
that atoll and you and i've talked about
this kind of aura of invincibility this
expert authority bias and and yeah how
do you walk the tightrope because we
need authorities we live in an
anti-scientific age um and yet we we
have a natural desire to also want to be
free and have liberty in this country
unlike other countries um and so yeah
how do you balance that as a doctor as a
public figure who's perhaps one of the
most vocal you know kind of um you know
supporters of of
the scientific method in the public
discourse how do you balance those two
the competition for liberty on one side
and the competition for
following experts when it's warranted
yeah it's a very important and delicate
balance because what i want to see is
democratizing medicine
so many people now can capture their own
data and with support of algorithms they
can do doctor-less things but of course
doctors don't want them to do that for
the most part
and so we have to let go and but we also
obviously want to have this stuff
validated with scientific method that it
really works so that no one's getting
hurt that it you know leads to the right
screening whether it's skin cancers and
lesions or urinary tract infections skin
uh you know ear infections of children
uh heart rhythm all these things can now
be obtained with a reasonable uh
accuracy by a person without a doctor
right so this is really where this uh
change this shift is occurring because
algorithms don't just help clinicians
they help all people if they're used
properly but we have a problem our
little problem is that so little has
been validated
so we can't be pushing this too hard
until we get compelling evidence that it
works really well yeah i had dr peter
diamandis on last year and he's famous
for all this democracy all these five ds
you know probably because his name is
diamandis has so many d's in it
uh but you know he's obviously on the
cutting edge of a lot of medical
research but also on you know kind of
the exponential all these different
exponentials that come into play
um and uh i think it's fascinating that
yeah we never has there been you know
misquote carl sagan you know never has
so much data been available so many
people who don't know how to use it it's
like
it's like uh you know there's there's
you know it'd be great if we could
actually have the kind of supervising
agent not not uh not um have to be so
hard to to come about in terms of a
trained doctor let me ask you a bigger
picture question i want to take you back
to to college and you're sleeping on the
you're chatting with your buddies on the
couch in the dorm or maybe you got a
beverage of your adult variety and and i
want to speculate what is when i say
life you know what is life to you
there's a famous paper monograph by
erwin schrodinger nobel prize winner for
creation of wave mechanics quantum
mechanics he wrote a monograph it
basically had some cool things in it
like hinted that there might be some
crystal inside life that that quant
stores information what is life to you
doctor
oh brian that's a tough one um you know
there's a recent book by
uh carl zimmer who's a real good friend
and journalist the new york times that
you know
several hundred pages that gets into
this is not an easy answer i mean you
know you could say it's a virus
life like that's my next question right
my next question and
you could say well not really and
nothing can get into a host right and
then it's then it sure is a hell of a
life and causing death but
of of the hosts and and um so it's
tricky because if if you want to talk
about independent ability to sustain
itself versus
uh being able to invade and then
basically you know hijack a host of any
kind there's lots of fine lines between
life here and and
sub-life forms so i you know in the true
sense it would be
you know that an organism that can
sustain itself replicate itself perhaps
but i think we have to think more
broadly than that
and then when i say artificial
intelligence my friend max tag mart
teg mark at mit was on the show um he's
a proponent of this concept that he
calls life 3.0 yeah actually artificial
intelligence has all the characteristics
that could plausibly from a physicist's
point of view perhaps be ascribed to a
living organism what do you make of that
yeah i think max's book 3.0 is actually
very provocative i i enjoyed it i
haven't met max but i certainly think
he's a
sharp thinker uh i don't want to give
agi
which he forecasts will be 2045 with his
uh big conference that he pulled
together
if that ever happens if that ever
happens maybe he'd be right but right
now you know i'm not thinking 2045 or
beyond that and i don't know that i
would give agi uh signing life potential
yet and we'll have to see whether that
actually pans out
you know one of the things i've gotten
interested in is kind of taking the
words of the great maestro of physics
galileo for the first time making the
first ever audiobook with some colleague
carlo robelli and others and
when i had the audio i actually realized
there is no audiobook of any of
galileo's works which is really a
tragedy so i'm rectifying that but i
said i actually have now i have the text
so could i put that into gpt-3
and make artificial galileo or as i call
them gala a-i-o
and start doing things with it but but
then it started down on me that you know
uh so einstein you may or may not know
this he called um the realization of
what's known as the equivalence
principle that if you're in free fall
you experience no gravitational force so
even if you're near you know that's the
sensation that you have when you're go
over a hill or in a plane or something
like that or if you're in a rocket in
deep space you're moving at one g you
can't tell you're not in a gravitational
field stationary on earth he called that
uh eric he called that the happiest
thought of his life and i started
thinking first of all could a computer
experience happiness number one uh and
then number two could it even relate
what does it mean to feel like you're
free falling and so i agree with you i'm
actually an ai pessimist or gai pe like
i don't think that it will be in the
same as i quote you know often you
mentioned kasparov he was beaten by deep
blue i know computers can now defeat any
human in chess can they create the game
of chess can computers eventually come
up with new ways of treating like kind
of some new idea actually you have to
remove all the mitochondria from every i
don't know i'll make it
the last thing i had in biology eric was
ninth grade i dissected a frog i got it
all wrong the frog lived the frog
actually lit i don't know how i'm such a
failure but yeah i mean are there
opportunities for like completely you
know de novo innovations in
either machine learning and deep from
deep neural networks like you talk about
in here or an ai is there any
possibility we just think so outside the
box literally the silicon box that it
could really surprise us in the way that
einstein was surprised in a similar
fashion
well i think it's speculative we haven't
seen it yet
we have seen you know amazing things
that we have to be imaginative that we
can train machines with the right inputs
to get outputs that were not envisioned
but what you're getting at is con
the autonomous aspect
of of neural nets to be able to do
things that you know without any
guidance whatsoever
uh i don't know about that i'm much more
skeptical that that's going to be
happening
but you know there are these people that
have you know the doomsayers like elon
musk and uh
and several others that have basically
you know gone that direction
you know it's possible
i don't think we've seen any good
evidence of it but i also would say you
know right now deep learning is the
vogue you know it's the main thing that
we
harp on but there are lots of new models
that are going to be
um
come up with in the years ahead and you
know anything's possible we should be
open to potential
you know and watch for that but i don't
see it uh you know i i i i'm more like
you on this not having heard your views
before
and now one of my favorite chapters in
deep medicine is a chapter called deep
empathy uh can you explain what that
means for people that haven't read the
book what does deep empathy mean right
so you know you already in a way um
came on to this with this assigning
human
qualities
to machines
which is wrong because there's no reason
to get in on anthropomorphic with the
machines so they're not going to have to
have empathy you can't you just can't do
that the that is i remember in the book
i had a table before that chapter about
all the things that humans do that
machines
can't really do whether it's cry or
laugh or you have true empathy and on
and on but the deep emphasis the the
final chapter the culmination of the
book is
how we get back this deep connection
between the patient and the clinician
because
it's
it's what it's all about that's for the
essentiality of medicine and yeah you
can have help with a machine to get
whether you know to get the right
diagnosis or even to guide towards the
right treatment but all that is
unimportant because when you're sick
you want a human looking after you you
want to know that a human has your back
and so that's deep empathy having your
back
having a presence a trust all the
qualities that are humanoid that we
don't have enough of today because we
don't have the gift of time one of my
favorite tweets that you had pinned on
your twitter profile where you've got
nyam 500 000 followers that are rabid
and love in the best sense i shouldn't
say rabbit to a physician
could be taken the wrong way uh but um
but you had a tweet pinned for a long
time and it was just your period medical
period data and uh you know
it strikes me that you're one of the
more along with atool and and others you
know very patient focus but i wanted to
take a step back because i teach a lot
of pre-meds um at ucsd in physics they
have to take you know physics one series
and i guess and you know they think it's
just to get past the mcats i wish that
they would actually learn it in a more
uh provocative and and actually
intellectual fashion then but you know
we do have to do that and so it's what
they do
a friend actually a friend of a friend
who's a famous podcaster in england he's
a doctor ali abdal he has two million
followers you know on on youtube anyway
he did a survey he dropped out of being
he was came cambridge trained a
physician ob gyn and he decided he's
just going to stop and he asked and
because he became a millionaire he
became a millionaire from youtube and
from he runs a bunch of courses and how
to study for med school and so
and he surveyed a bunch of his friends
that are doctors and said if you became
a millionaire
would you keep practicing and and most
of the answers eric came back as yes
until the end of the day
in other words there's so much
dissatisfaction there's so much burnout
there's so much stress among your fellow
physicians that i wonder like who speaks
for them and is that a crisis this
crisis of meaning or cri burnout what do
you make of that yeah i know you're
you're spot on about that so we have a
global crisis of burnout the highest
rate of clinical depression suicides
ever in the medical profession not even
just among doctors but nurses and other
disciplines it's it's actually horrific
um the pandemic has
has um put medicine in a a bright light
in terms of heroes if you will but it
hasn't gotten
over this problem of loss of mission so
the point being here is that when you
can't when you only have seven minutes
to see patients
and 12 minutes for a new patient that
you've never seen before
you
you basically are violating why you did
this for your life
because you did it because you care for
people you want to care for people you
want to look after them and you can so
that's what leads to profound
disenchantment is unable to cope with
the system of how you are basically um
supposed to be practicing medicine that
has to change
um and the overlords basically in
medicine
unlike your walk of life are managers
bean counters and they want you to see
more patients
in any given time slot so that doesn't
work out too well so the only way we get
over this is that we have to revolt
we have to tell the
the
the managers
that no we're not doing this anymore we
want to look after patients because if
we don't do that
we it's hard to break this
progressive
crisis global disenchantment and
depression it's been a it's been
building you know over many years
and when we think about you know kind of
how these students come up and the
shortage of physicians i had um
michael saylor who's a very big
proponent of bitcoin not that we're
going to get into that but he's one of
them for and anyway he started this new
university basically for stem and it's
called sailor academy and he basically
feels like unless you're going to be you
know like a sculptor or you know major
in professional golf i don't know well
i'm talking to a doctor so maybe you
can't major in professional i don't know
but uh
but the point is like for at least for
not physical interactions you know maybe
maybe there is some part of the bedside
you know manner that you can't teach but
you know could we could we you know kind
of lessen the pressure on the existing
cadre of doctors by having just more and
more students get into medicine and by
doing so lower the cost of medical
school make it more affordable make
their more trainer you know teachers etc
you know why have brian keating you know
teach physics when you can have galileo
or einstein using ai and all the words
they've ever spoken do you see an
opportunity or would it make the problem
worse to have more people become
physicians would you just have a greater
number of suicides and sort of negative
mental health outcomes well it's a very
good uh insightful question you know the
problem is right now the the workforce
the
the human capital that's being expended
is making health care uh unsustainable
so we have to be smarter about that and
the question is of course
if we got more frontline people like
you're alluding to
and stop with all these administrators
and managers whose role is more
questionable that's one strategy but the
other one is to rely much more on
support that we can get from machines
that can
make
each doctor's life so much easier and
more accurate so
i think it's a combination of those two
not one or the other
and uh so i think that that you know
dovetails nicely into kind of
transitioning to rather uh you know
current events let's call it current
events
uh there's been a a perversive worldwide
pandemic for the last uh 16 or more
months i've heard of that yeah
are you familiar with this because i
have a doctor a friend of mine i happen
to know eric topol so i can interview i
can put you in touch but um well first
of all i want to get your just as a
human being so i remember in january
2020 i'd just been invited to go to a
conference in tibet of all places and i
was looking forward to i've never been
to china to tibet and i went to dinner
and i was next to a friend of mine my
friend mitch and and he was saying you
might want to like hold off on that a
little bit because i just heard you know
china's building this hospital and
there's so much far in advance of
america that uh they built the hospital
in seven days and it can hold a thousand
people and it also doubles maybe as some
other anyway i don't get into politics
but but the point was they were like my
friend mitch who's not like a global
policy medical health pandemic expert or
you know doesn't have the trillion
dollar nsa budget cia budget whatever
all these three little darpa whatever
he knew about it he knew it was not a
good he knew it was coming to america
and canada
how come we failed so badly to diagnose
this and it wasn't like we didn't know
it could happen but with all the
apparatus in other words not just like
oh well you know we had a bad president
or a good pre whatever again i'm not
political i'm a political atheist and i
think i got into astronomy eric just to
sign up because there are no like
republican constellations there's no
democratic asteroid over there you know
i love it because i think we need a
politics free space as intellectuals in
society but anyway i agree with that i
don't just like there's not a democratic
or republican virus either yes exactly
so the the issue here is that um we were
flat-footed and
the biggest singular problem
why the u.s got so deep into a horrible
mess is that we had no testing
capability for the first two months of
the pandemic here
and so without testing
we watched
unknowingly this the diffuse
spread
of uh the coronavirus you know
everywhere
and so
that was the time when you needed to
have it was basically invisible to us
and the only way to see it would have
been to do nasopharyngeal suaves and pcr
so we blew it and now we're trying to
dig out and uh you know it's just really
when you get that far behind two months
i mean as you know talk about
exponential stuff right
you're in deep [ __ ] i mean you know you
and we are still
um in in many ways from that now had we
been all over it you know like iceland
is an example you say oh well that's
just an island country it's only got 300
000 people but hey they were testing
people randomly before the pandemic ever
reached there that's the way to be right
and so you you look at the countries
that got to zero covet and they were
basically all over from the get-go now
you could say in the second
part of the story
they're all
basically naive
they have no immunity and so they have
to also be smart about getting
vaccine-induced immunity but at least to
get through and have unscathed like you
know i have a faculty appointment at the
university of auckland in new zealand i
talk to my colleagues you know
frequently and to think
that they basically have had a normal
life never been affected by covet except
for a few days here and there because
they got all over it from from the
beginning and they stayed all over it
and they're also doing well now in the
vaccination phase so there are ways that
you we could have done so much better
and it was just mismanaged and i think
you know our public health resources
were gutted
you know systematically gutted over many
years so we were in the poor position
to to to react
and even knowing you know when the
sequence of the virus was available
on january 10th from china
that was the triumph of the american
medicine life science community of
getting the vaccines you know compressed
schedule all the way highly successful
vaccines all the way through clinical
trials and rolling out within 10 months
that's amazing so you have you know the
best and the worst right you have
what the us is very good at which is on
the life science industry
and ingenuity side but on the public
health pitiful
yeah i see that especially as a parent
of young kids and seeing you know just
kind of the various whip sawing i felt
like over the past year and a half and
still feeling like oh now we've got this
delta variant um
so you talked a little bit about this in
a wonderful chat with sam harris a
couple weeks ago but i want to ask you
um like when they say you know this is
spreading we have a new wave etc um how
different in terms of viral if you just
took you know the pcr of it first of all
how do they know it's you know if
someone goes in the hospital in san
diego god forbid and they have covet you
know how do they do they actually test
and say oh this is a delta person not
versus i mean do they do that or well in
san diego we're very lucky because we
have if not the most sequencing yeah
maybe the second most sequencing of any
prayer in the country right so
fortunately our collaboration at scripps
research with ucsd
and helix and illumina we're all over
this so we do sequence the samples and
interestingly to that point uh brian
when we had the original virus and then
the alpha variant and the other variants
before delta we could hardly ever
sequence the virus in the samples there
was so little there now every one of
them can be sequenced because there's so
much and the key thing here is that it's
a thousand-fold more viral load
so when you get the chance of overriding
vaccines even can occur but moreover the
people who are unvaccinated are just
spreading this like no other previous
version of the virus it's just so
super contagious unfortunately and
that's why it's causing real havoc and
not as much yet in california hopefully
but it certainly is in many other states
in the country
and looking at the you know the data and
seeing you know the the prevalence of
both of hospitalization with and without
vaccination i think it's really clear
and i you know i got the vaccine at ucsd
i think we had one of the best response
i was never more proud to be at ucsd you
know we had we had vending machines with
test swab kits i could get it whenever i
wanted we had you know distance we had
mask you know we did it all as soon as
the vaccine was ready i was one of the
first people i got my wife
and now it's like i don't even know
where to get one you know if you wanted
to get one uh it's it's it seems like
you know perhaps we have to revitalize
that whole campaign but i think ucsd and
the chancellor and the med school and
everybody and scripps as well did a
phenomenal job and i want to thank you
and in the role that you played and also
our chancellor as i said um and i'm not
just saying that because he's my boss
but but anyway
no he's a good he's a good man but i
also think we're very lucky that we
worked together in san diego there was
no you know uh sense of uh rivalry we we
and this the county the san diego county
i mean three and a half million people
second largest in california we got on
this and so it isn't perfect but we
actually are a model county um like
seattle uh kings county and a few others
around the country that have managed
this reasonably well i mean you know
you've got wastewater surveillance there
on campus
we're trying to stay ahead of it uh you
know the one thing i regret uh here is
that we didn't get the rapid home
testing to every household in san diego
to show the rest of the country that
that would be uh so striking in terms of
helping to manage so anytime you're
going out you would be
clear that you're not infectious and we
need that now more than ever because
some vaccinated people are unknowingly
uh infected
and
what do you make of it though i have you
know people on you know other side just
to just to have some potential pushback
on some of the messaging that's been
gotten you know if you have a vaccine
if you're vaccinated rather double
vaccinated it's it worked well um you
know why should you have to wear a mask
and i hear that a lot and i just want to
get your
personal take on it because i know
you've been kind of atheistic
politically too in that you've pushed
back on big pharma in the past famously
against merck and vioxx and now you know
more recently kind of just criticizing
some of the current cdc messaging um
what do you make of that if you were
talking to someone who's bright and just
say this is the first just stating in
fact this first vaccine that you have to
you know wear a mask after you got
vaccinated and had some high efficacy
and efficiency as you point out in your
interview with sam what do you mean well
here you bring in a little physics with
the aerosol transmission right and when
you have a thousand fold more viral load
the chance of you being able to override
a person who is doubly vaccinated is
higher we're seeing it we're seeing
these so-called breakthroughs and not
just
that they get a positive test but they
get symptoms and some get you know quite
sick obviously the chance of it is much
lower than
far lower than if you're unvaccinated
but
it's all about the fact that this virus
is distinctly diversion it's distinctly
worse and different and more challenging
it's daunting um compared with every
prior version and the other thing is it
also has this quality of immune
evasiveness
so whereas the prior
versions of the virus the vaccine held
up really well here one dose is like
placebo you know if you don't have the
second dose
you got a lot of vulnerability so
basically the the vaccines are leaking
uh the the viral load is overwhelming
people and the other thing is which is
unanticipated now get into the weeds of
life science we thought that our b cells
and t cells were going to kick in these
on-demand reserve cells and that we'd be
good for years like you know 10 20 years
now it looks like we're only good for a
matter of months and we have to get
boosters and so it's becoming much more
complicated
in terms of those boosters you know i've
had friends of mine actually physicians
just saying like oh yeah i just i'm
going to go down and and i and if this
is misinformation please correct me but
you know that they would get another
boost they would just go and get another
coveted shot and go over to vaccination
is that advisable is that not recommend
i mean if it's safe in other words they
they're the reasoning that these
physicians have told me it's safe we
know it's almost as as effective as a
vaccine has ever been made in human
history
as you pointed out thanks to this
immense ingenuity of people around the
world but especially people here locally
uh
and yet it's so safe so why not just get
a third you know wouldn't it be
prophylactic in the sense yeah i mean i
think it's still some unknowns like is
this only for people of advanced age and
immunocompromise
is this an across-the-board thing
is this like what timing is it six
months nine months i mean there's a lot
of unknowns so before we start you know
getting to third boosters we're learning
from israel which has started that
campaign of a third in the elderly
population but it's a little early to
jump to that um ideally
if you know this delta wave could pass
pretty quickly and we won't have to
worry about it so much
in some places its rise is complemented
fortunately by its rapid fall off so if
we see that you know then and if the
virus isn't circulating high levels then
the need for the boosters will be for
stall you know and then we can look at
it and think about in the light of day
rather than a panic mode where we have
insufficient data right now
i want to ask you a question that my
audience had but also i had and um
and and actually it was brought to my
attention by andy weir
the author of the martian and more
recently project hail mary which is
about a virus that doesn't take over the
earth it takes over the sun anyway he's
a he's a proud dropout of ucsd uh in the
computer science division where our
mutual friend regis gupta connected you
and me together i thank you very much
shout out to rajesh he's an unbelievable
uh scientist and and influence on me uh
i want to ask you um is this as andy
said maybe the last pandemic in other
words now that we have mnrna mrna and we
have you know 3d printing we have crispr
we have
is this the last you know that we might
it might be a side benefit of covid that
that we won't suffer from a global
pandemic again
well i'm an optimist uh brian and
i think it's possible that we could
markedly reduce the chances
that we'll have another pandemic if
we have developed
stockpiles of universal vaccines against
all the candidate viruses
so basically
because of what we now can do with
structural biology
and with crispr
and you know all the tools that we have
we can basically take down all
coronaviruses
and other
viruses that would likely yield a
pandemic such that the moment we saw
it start in an outbreak we would be you
know at um all over it and have the
uh the tools to squash it
so
that we would never get in this kind of
situation again but
that relies on heavy investment in the
life science to have those
pan virus
all the candidates there's a list of
like five or six families and we have
the ability now we're smart enough to
know whether it's through natural
antibody reverse engineering that people
make these incredibly potent antibodies
super antibodies or whether it's through
synthetic means we could do this
but we have to fund it we have to you
know put the resources and the
intellectual talent behind it but
i do think the chances will be blunted
it will never be zero and it could be
that the top five virus families that we
think are
are it and we and we get a surprise you
know so um that's what we should be
aiming for right now is having
preparation where we basically have a
way to squash this from the get-go
another question uh from a listener um
or viewer on youtube who has a name
actually i chose i was gonna choose from
my
oldest son
but his name is stinky piece of cheese
uh and yet and yet he asked a very or
she asked i don't know it could be a
woman uh asked a very provocative and
interesting question um about the future
of technology not just ai but
he asks or she asks other than ecg pulse
oximetry galvanic response temperature
and blood insulin and other things
oxygenation um what other non-invasive
sensors look promising to provide
real-time specific patient data for
input
oh i think it's immense actually
uh just voice is a big one
um there's going to be
a ability to
for a breath
to you know all the
being able to pick up
all the organic
molecules in the person's breath i mean
it's just unlimited we have basically we
have all these
uh exhaust fumes
as as human machines that we are more
than others more than others yeah some
more than others that we haven't tapped
into yet so no i think that the
non-invasive sensor world is uh is going
to be rich and we're just barely
scratching the surface and stinky
piece of cheese started with a few there
but there's a whole lot more really
that's right the stinkiness the breath
maybe could could perhaps provide vital
clues as to his or her health another
question from a listener second choice
for a name for one of my kids
zero skull okay zero skull asks um is
there any such thing as a typical human
i see online often and maybe i've even
seen you retweet this you know there'll
be some study you know like
coffee more than three cups of coffee a
day kills you know you with 100
certainty in 100 years yeah but in mice
you know
it's always in mice and we by the way
i've i've coined another one instead of
just say mice it's just say dust because
dust is responsible for most of the like
hoaxes and problems in astronomy that we
see but anyway um he's asking does any
human that you've ever encountered or
examined meet the physiological
psychological sociological definition of
a typical human and if not is that a
problem
yeah i think that's the principle of
individualized medicine
that every one of us is unique
biologically anatomically our
environment
you know physiologically every layer we
are unique so that's why
in many respects um we we try to dumb
down medicine with the clinical trial in
the clinical trial you know this
that's the sanctimonious clinical trial
where you have 10 people out of 100
derived benefit right right and then you
treat everyone with that treatment well
what about the 90 that don't have
benefit right so we have basically all
these pills that people are taking every
day and we don't even know if they
benefit because they like the
the five or the 10 out of 100 that do
benefit or they like the 90 or the 85
they don't i mean we we are so stupid we
have to be smarter than this because the
waste is profound right and it isn't
just the cost it's also exposure to side
effects and you know taking some pill
for the rest of your life and so many so
we have to do better than this to
understand and that's part of the deep
medicine principle is deep phenotyping
that we understand each person at this
kind of multi-dimensional
um
way and uh you know we we can do that
now we just aren't doing it um
question from a fourth year medical
student named nicholas primiano i can't
believe that's his real name
his real name has got to be you know
oblong footballers and anyway now this
is a real person with the real picture
nicholas asks you um and this is related
i think to your conversation with sam
harris uh you talked about the vaccine
reporting system and how it's over
reporting adverse events by three orders
of magnitude this is according to him
i'm just taking his word for it i have
no reason to suspect anyone but he said
is it okay
uh to exaggerate health issues in the
name of greater good of public safety
and actually this i've thought about
this too it was admitted not too long
ago that the you know that some breast
cancer
advocacy group you know advocated that
all women get mammograms or some anyway
there was a controversy about mammograms
i remember very strikingly and
secondhand smoke and which you did
mention with sam as an example of like
something that you know is not really
transmissible anyway there was a long
ago the american lung association you
know had statistics like you know you're
20 times more likely to die of
secondhand and now we don't really talk
about it because it was so successful
and obviously women getting early
screening and surveillance for breast
cancer is a net positive and people not
smoking and not impacting people with
secondhand smoke is a benefit now the
question i think nicholas is asking is
you know to what extent is it okay to to
exaggerate medical benefits in the name
of public health i i know you're not a
public you know right
yeah i think
you're you touched on mammography and
that's a great example because the
benefits have been grossly exaggerated
so if you take 10 000 women the
prototypic risk at age 50 and you have
them get a mammogram every
year for 10 years
you find out that there's a 60
false positive rate yeah but all these
poor women that are told there's
something abnormal many of them get
biopsies some of them even get treated
uh in surgery so you have all these
false positives for the very small few
people that you've helped right a few
over the course of a decade so
when you exaggerate things the
implications from a public health
standpoint are profound it's kind of
like the algorithm that goes into scale
in people and there's a glitch in it and
you can hurt a lot of people real
quickly that's what you can do if you
exaggerate the benefits or the harms now
when i was talking about the the vaccine
adverse event
recording system that was the same sort
of thing as exaggerating the harms
because none of these
none of these reported things are
are reviewed or adjudicated and so a lot
of them have nothing to do with the
vaccine in fact most
so we have to be accurate again with
this whether it's you know a particular
intervention screening
the results of a treatment like the
vaccines all these things require
accuracy and when they're loose
we got problems
so last question from the audience uh
has to do with uh whether or not
i don't know why he's asking you this
but he's asking you
uh is there an ontological is there a
moral imperative rather for humans to
colonize other planets
well that's an interesting question um
you know i listened to jeff bezos on his
recent uh little trip a little adventure
about how important it is and um
how
it will be the way to save the planet
and you know a lot of theoretical things
right
uh maybe maybe
uh i can see it um as a potential thing
i i think the problem and this is where
you know i got involved a little bit um
with uh the kelly uh
brothers the the traveling in space for
human beings we're not fit
we're not fit to be
if you go hang out in the iss for any
undue period of time or try to take a
little trip to mars
it's going to really have a big hit on
your body and we don't know who are the
right what's right genome and right
people that are going to withstand that
hit i mean humans weren't meant for this
so there's some trade-offs brian i think
there's some benefits potentially but we
haven't weighed the toll it takes
on
scott kelly when he was compared to his
brother mark who never left you know uh
so
it's an unknown and i think we have some
of these you know between branson and
musk and and bezos we have these
incredible advocates but i don't think
we've carefully considered some of the
tradeoffs to the human toll on your body
yeah no i agree and just as a point of
reference i had jessica myer who's from
the other scripps institution of
oceanography i interviewed her live
while she was on the iss and she seemed
to be doing well she enjoyed her hair
kind of floating around but she she uh
answered questions from middle school
and high school kids around the county
and then i had lord martin reese who's
the astronomer royale and tells the
queen her horoscope i guess but anyway
he he was on the show and he said yes uh
elon elon told me that he wants to die
on mars and i said i just hope it's not
on impact
so we're going to go into the impossible
which is when i do questions only for my
members and subscribers and i don't want
to deny my non-members and
non-subscribers the opportunity to hear
just your last thoughts about um about
kovid what this wave was likely to do
any imprecations any implorations uh
what do you think what would you like to
leave the vast majority of my audience
with today
well like i said brian i'm an optimist
and i have watched the other countries
where this wave
it was severe but it passed through
relatively quickly shorter than prior
partly because the virus is so
incredibly efficient burns through
populations uh and and then it can't
find hosts and it retreats partly
because in some places we've had you
know good vaccination to help
give some line of defense so i'm hoping
that in the next several weeks it'll be
passed but i don't know what lurks after
that i i don't know whether it'll it'll
come back uh whether we'll see a worse
variant i'm hoping not i mean this is
pretty darn bad
pretty damn bad so let's just hope that
we're over the biggest hump
because eventually um there is the the
worry that we could see a virus with
even more immune evasiveness and make
our vaccines look even weaker
um so let's hope that we don't see that
yeah so i mean i think we're both
encouraging people if they're meet the
requirements to get vaccinated and uh
take proper precautions and not be too
you know i always think being an
optimist is dangerous and being a
pessimist is dangerous because they can
both lead you to inaction but uh but i
want to thank you dr eric topel of the
scripps institute and an uh institution
i always get the two of them scripps
research institution that's the way i'll
remember it i want to thank you so much
and if you'll uh indulge me i have five
more minutes of questions just from my
members and audience called into the
impossible will ask them final big
philosophical picture questions but for
now eric thank you so much for going
into the impossible thank you
any sufficiently advanced technology is
indistinguishable from magic
[Music]
if you enjoyed this video i know you'll
love my interview with peter diamandis a
fellow doctor and proponent of all
things technical applied to medicine and
don't forget to subscribe if you want to
receive eric's answers to my thrilling
three final existential questions you'll
need to go over to my website to sign up
brianketing.com
you